[Música]
las elecciones regionales de este
domingo 21 de noviembre en venezuela se
realizarán con la participación de un
sector de la oposición tras cuatro años
de estrategias abstencionistas en las
pasadas elecciones las encuestas
pronostican que tras las divisiones la
mayoría de las 23 gobernaciones
quedarían en manos del chavismo pero que
la oposición puede haber recuperado
espacios de influencia electoral los
venezolanos van a votar por 23
gobernaciones y 335 alcaldías entre
otros cargos locales para ello quiero
saludar entonces a mi segundo invitado
el dial es oswaldo ramírez director de
rc consultores osvaldo gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa muy buen
día para ti le pregunto queda en juego
en estas elecciones del domingo en
venezuela
buenos dias raúl un placer para todos
los que nos están viendo mira está en
juego la para algunos la posibilidad
cierta de plantear una nueva ruta
estratégica de cara a las elecciones
presidenciales del año 2024 ok esto en
primer término la intención de
participar ahora está rondando entre 44
y el 47 por ciento del padrón electoral
son 21 puntos 2 millones de electores en
donde muy lamentablemente no se conoce
el peso del número de venezolanos que
tuvieron que emigrar sea planificada o
forzadamente y que no estamos
participando en el proceso electoral y
lo segundo es que está claramente en el
sentimiento del elector enfocado en
resolver asuntos netamente mundanos de
política pública doméstica para las
alcaldías de ciertos elementos
de mantenimiento de poder para las
gobernaciones pero claramente no existe
una situación que diga vamos a ir a
votar para cambiar el poder por lo tanto
hay una potencial a alta tensión
ahora es valdo porque la oposición
decidió volver en estas elecciones qué
pasa con la oposición venezolana ya pues
realmente fragmentada además
y un sector importante de los que venían
ejerciendo vidas dentro de la plataforma
unitaria que apoyaba es el gobierno
interino juan guaidó decidieron
participar efectivamente no existe una
oposición en venezuela están los grupos
que adversan al gobierno algunos de
ellos incluso yo creo que esos clientes
específicos del gobierno estamos
hablando de 5 coaliciones que adversan
al gobierno y tres de ellas están
participando en la elección pero existe
una especie de divorcio absoluto de
acción política de ideología política
que yo creo que imposibilita de manera
bien significativa la posibilidad de que
todos estos actores puedan unirse en un
frente único
osvaldo garantías electorales para estos
comicios del próximo domingo como ven
los venezolanos al consejo nacional
electoral realmente confían en este ente
por muchos años ligados al chavismo
en los estudios más recientes de rsa
consultores encontramos que la confianza
en el consejo nacional electoral mejoro
mejoró hoy está en números positivos
esos niveles de confianza
cerca de 46 por ciento del país está
confiando en el cn en este consejo
electoral cuando el histórico entre el
2004 y el 2020 estaba cerca del 65 por
ciento de desconfianza o sea viéndolo de
revés en 35 por ciento de confianza esto
es significativo puede cambiar si lo que
los electores ven el día domingo es que
lamentablemente no se respetó esa esta
voluntad del votante es decir que fue a
votar más no le permitieron elegir a los
gobernantes que estaba aspirado osvaldo
como se encuentra venezuela en la
actualidad como llega el país a estas
elecciones del domingo
y estamos estamos entendiendo un país
que tiene dos características la primera
es un pragmatismo económico por parte
del régimen de nicolás maduros que ha
llevado a que la gente se concentre
simplemente en producir dinero esto de
la mano de una dolarización
transaccional muy desordenada no
completamente no está tocando
completamente a todos los sectores de la
población pero para entenderlo más o
menos dos de cada tres venezolanos hoy
tienen acceso a divisas en alguna forma
esto ha mejorado muy levemente ciertos
indicadores de alimentación ciertos
indicadores de esta crisis humanitaria
compleja que a través de la nación y la
segunda continúa con un proceso bien
crítico en una crisis institucional de
una crisis de liderazgo en general y eso
lleva al ciudadano a un efecto
despolitización es simplemente no crea
un partido no crea un liderazgo
simplemente me concentro en mi vida
personal y esto me lleva a tomar
decisiones que me alejan de la política
y esas decisiones son netamente
económicas de gm en espacio tranquilo
para yo poder producir ahora luego el
domingo como a quedar entonces las
fuerzas políticas en venezuela que se
puede pronosticar
mira como lo decías al inicio no es una
elección nacional son estamos hablando
de 23 elecciones de carácter regional
335 elecciones de carácter local lo que
estamos viendo en números nacionales
como una variable de aproximación es que
está polarizada la elección entre la
tarjeta del psv y la tarjeta de la
plataforma unitaria esta tarjeta que en
un proceso de negociación fue regresada
a los partidos mayoritarios pero cuando
los aliados del oficialismo obligar a un
pueblo patriótico porque de chavistas
descontentos con maduro y que no quieren
votar el partido tradicional de ellos
votan por esos candidatos aumenta el
caudal de votación estamos hablando que
esto nos permite proyectar en un
escenario relativamente bajo de baja
participación que el oficialismo pudiera
estar alcanzando al menos con seguridad
unas 12 gobernaciones y luego tendrían
mayor competencia para la oposición en
al menos unas 7 u 8 govern azul esto
osvaldo ya para finalizar cambiaría
entonces algo de lo que ocurre en
venezuela la crisis la puede solucionar
esta votación
no no la resuelve pero para algunos hace
un planteamiento
si se llega a una elección con unas
condiciones mínimas vamos a ver si
efectivamente esas condiciones se
respetan hay una novedad desde hace 16
años no había una observación
internacional independiente como tenemos
hoy con la unión europea y así como
otros observadores centro cárter
etcétera
si comienzas a trabajar en un aumento de
potenciales condiciones electorales de
cara a la alimentación de una ruta 2022
2024 pudiera generar mayor momento
necesita ser un trabajo mucho más grande
pero en el fondo nicolás maduro necesita
llevar a la cara lavar la cara de cierta
manera para la comunidad internacional
con la búsqueda de un
desmontaje de las sanciones impuestas
particularmente por eeuu en temas
financieros yo creo que van a estar
concentrando su agenda en potencialmente
regresar a mexico negociaciones y tratar
de decir señores respetamos la elección
hubo una elección transparente por favor
ayúdenme a levantar esa